- All right.
Welcome back everybody.
We are here with the stars
of John Wick, Chapter Four
Keanu Reeves, Ian McShane
and Lance Reddick.
The movie introduces us
to a number of new, complicated,
pretty rad characters.
Two of those are played
by these next two guys.
Please welcome the Tracker and the Manager
of the Osaka Continental Hotel,
Shamier Anderson
and Hiroyuki Sanada.
(crowd cheers and applauds)
(upbeat intro music)
(crowd applauds)
(crowd cheers and applauds)
(upbeat intro music)
- How are you man?
- Alright.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
Come on down.
Hiro, Hiroyuki.
Oh, you're gonna go see the puppies.
I know.
Look, they're crashed now.
- Oh, they're-
- They're crashed now. Yeah.
- Sleeping time now.
- It's National Puppy Day, y'all.
- So cute.
I can't take, I already
have two dogs and two kids
and I'm single, so it's like a lot.
So I can't take any,
I can't take anymore.
Look at the little paws.
I know they're so cute.
First of all, you guys, thank
you so much for being here.
I love your characters.
Like, I love the family dynamic
not only between you and the,
your daughter in the film
but you and your dog in the film,
who is gnarly.
- Yes. Yes.
- [Kelly] You say attack.
I love that you literally,
are you saying nuts?
- I'm saying nuts.
- Is that what you're saying?
- Yeah. Yeah. I say
nuts. I say nuts. That's-
- And well, the dog attacks.
So describe who you play to everybody.
- So I play the Tracker.
He's a new character in
the John Wick franchise
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And essentially
exactly what his name is.
He's tracking John Wick.
He's coming to this wacky world
and he has a companion,
who I call "the puppy".
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And he gets to work
with this, you know, dog.
- [Kelly] Puppy.
- Yes. I call him the puppy.
It's very endearing, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah. Cujo?
(Kelly laughs)
- It's very endearing.
It's very endearing.
And it's, it's been a fun ride.
And got to work with this incredible puppy
and chase, John Wick.
- What a fun character too?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The character's incredible.
- Cause you're badass
- Pretty badass.
- You know that knife scene,
I was like, (Kelly squeals)
- Yes.
- With your hand. I was like, no.
- Girls guard, bang.
- You know, I'd have just
been like boo in his neck.
Any way,
that says a lot about me.
I know, I'm like one of those nerds
watching, going,
nah, man, you should have, nevermind.
So Hiroyuki,
So tell everybody your character.
- Oh, thank you.
Please call me Hiro.
- Okay. Hiro. Oh, I love that.
- And I play
Koji Shimazu,
manager of Osaka Continental Hotel.
And also old friend.
- [Keanu] Old friend.
- [Hiroyuki] John Wick.
John and then Koji
Shimazu grown up together
trained together, maybe
helping each other,
almost like a
brother.
But when I had a daughter,
I tried to, you know
go into the peaceful life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Hiroyuki] And,
- He kind of messed that up.
- Yeah, yeah.
Became a manager
and you know
- Get a desk job.
Yeah.
- Spending a peaceful
- Yeah.
- Time until
somebody
visited me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So,
- and then just literally
all hell breaks loose.
- Yeah. But brotherhood
is so important for him.
So struggle in his mind
struggling between old friend
or daughter,
family thing.
But I couldn't say no to him.
- Yeah.
- So I decided to
do something.
- I know, I love that
about your character.
I don't even know if I'm
just reading into this,
but I love that it seems
like your character is so,
there's no gray there's just like,
what you feel like is right
and you should do
and what is wrong.
And I love that.
Any way,
So Shamier,
is it, is it true that you
you have Halle Berry to
thank for getting the part?
Is this true?
- I mean, yeah.
Yeah. To, so to a certain degree.
So I worked on a film-
- I mean, obviously your talented.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- As well, yeah.
- She's great.
No, she's great.
She was also in the third John Wick.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah.
- As we all know.
And she also had dogs.
But I worked on her movie,
her directorial debut "Bruised".
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Shamier] And Chad Stahelski
was actually on that.
And there we are right there.
- [Shamier] And Chad was
actually on that movie.
Yes.
- [Shamier] That's Halle Berry.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And Chad got to help on that film
and he remembered me.
And so he called me and he said
I remember that guy Shamier Anderson
I want a meeting for the roll of Tracker.
And so I got the call, they're like,
"Hey, would you consider John Wick?".
I'm like, "Hey, whatever,
I'll do anything.
I'll suit the floors on
set, whatever you want."
- Yeah.
- And I got on the Zoom
and I had the meeting
with Chad Celeste, our filmmaker,
and then I, you know
texted Halle and I said,
"Hey, can you put in a good word?"
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then I guess one
thing led to the next
and I got the job
and I'm here.
- I just love that you just
like, texting Halle Berry.
That's amazing.
Like, okay, my life is different.
I don't, I don't text Halle Berry.
So he wrote,
I, I heard
that after your fight scenes in this movie
Keanu shared something
special with you, right?
- [Hiroyuki] Oh, yes.
What is that?
It was so helpful for me.
Can I talk about that?
- The psh, psh.
- Some kind of psh, psh.
- [Kelly] You can't
say, cannot not tell us.
- He had a secret weapon.
- Okay.
- Because
- We're old.
- We all have a,
- We're injured, we've done a lot.
- So many old injures.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So during fighting, well
after the fighting scene
use psh, psh machine,
it's kind of icing machine, right?
- Yes.
- An ice machine that goes psh?
- [Hiroyuki] Yes. Yeah.
- Very cold liquid or-
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Gas.
- Oh. And you can like target the area?
- Targeted ice.
- [Kelly] Yeah. I like it.
And then if it's enough,
automatically, automatically stop.
Oh, so not, not burn and save
and after use that feel
like a newborn baby.
I can, I can fight again.
- I need to get this machine.
Wait, what?
That's, how often do you use this?
Okay. So if you have
a machine, I feel like
there's a, a real need. Like-
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Do you have a
regular need for this?
- During John Wick, you, yes.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Yes.
Our next guest went from being
a stunt double for Keanu
in the first matrix movies to directing
the John Wick films.
One of the biggest action
franchises in movie history.
Please welcome, Chad Stahelski, y'all.
(crowd cheers and applauds)
(upbeat music)
- [Kelly] Yeah. I think you three.
Yeah. It's, it's full couches.
- I know.
- [Kelly] Look at this. Look at this.
You're welcome ladies.
So,
and fellas, whatever you're into.
- Hey, see how everybody else is sitting?
I wanna be, I wanna be masculine too.
- [Kelly] I wanna be masculine too.
Wait, thank you so much for being here.
- Thanks for having us.
- For sure.
Yes. I'm a huge fan.
As if you've been listening at all.
You know this, but as I
mentioned, you and Keanu
y'all go way back as the first matrix.
- I think it was
1996.
- No, '97.
- [Chad] No we-
- I love that he was like, you're way off.
It's like one year.
- I think we met at the auditions in '96.
- [Keanu] Oh okay.
- When I first auditioned for the job.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And then we met in Burbank, California
in an audition space up in,
up in Burbank.
- And you were a stunt double then?
That's what you?
I was a stunt man at the time.
- Yeah. That's cra- So you,
I just have a question about that so.
- [Chad] Sure.
- How'd you get into that?
- [Kelly] Just like jumping off shit or-
- Poor life choices.
- [Kelly] I was like
- Limited options, poor life choices.
- No, it just seems like a crazy job.
To be like, yes, I'm gonna do this.
- [Chad] No, it was great.
- I went to school at USC
at the University of Southern California.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And,
my parents were very athletic.
My family was athletic.
I was into a lot of martial arts
at the time
and was competing
and there was a stunt
coordinator in the audience.
And he came up to me after
the competition went,
"how would you like to be in movies?
And I was like, "sure."
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- And it was in this
really low budget movie
called Nemesis, an Albert Pyun movie.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like cyborg stuff.
- [Kelly] And look at you now.
Yes.
So Chad and Keanu,
this movie has an amazing action scene
with cars and I'm gonna run this,
but (speaking french), I
don't know how you say it.
Was that tough to do?
It was so cool.
Because I feel like
when you do the fourth movie
and then also like there's
a lot of action movies made.
Right?
I've never seen anything like that.
It was so cool.
It like played out.
Like how, how long did
it take to plan that?
Because the whole sequence is like
this giant circle of gunfire.
- I think Keanu, how long
were you driving for?
Maybe six months out before?
- No, no, I was only
driving like four or five.
- Four or five months out.
Sorry.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- He likes details.
- [Chad] Yeah, about
four or five months out
Keanu was driving
and then the sequence we were prepping
for about three months out.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- [Chad] But we had, I think it was like
30 stunt drivers plus
- [Kelly] It's like choreographed.
Yeah.
- [Chad] Yeah. It's hard to rehearse that.
So you kind of rehearse chunks
and then hope it all
fits together on the day.
- [Kelly] Oh my god. Poor guy.
That messes the whole thing up at the end.
- [Chad] Yeah. That would be bad.
- You know, like one guy
is like missed your mark.
- How many? We had two Barracudas.
We had one trophy Barracuda,
that hero car that Keanu drives.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Chad] And I think we,
no, we wrecked that one too.
I think we wrecked them.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Shamier] There was,
there was a little boo boo.
- [Chad] Yeah.
- We destroyed that too.
- Yeah.
- And I had a little boo boo.
- [Chad] There might have been some dents.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] It was worth it.
That is one of my
favorite scenes in a movie
like an action film.
I was like, "What? Still?
And it's still happening."
It was like, it just was incredible.
It was in incre- it was like a dance.
- Yeah.
- Of gunfire.
It was in incredible.
Good news, everybody.
The cast has something
super cool for everyone
in our audience today,
courtesy of our friends at Imax.
Everyone is getting two tickets
to see John Wick- Chapter Four.
(audience cheering and applauding)
It's such a great film.
Oh my god.
You're gonna love it.
Give it up one more time for the cast
of John Wick- Chapter Four,
y'all.
The movie is in theaters now.
Go see it.
And don't forget it's
National Puppy Day, everybody.
There are plenty of puppies
who are in need of adoption
including those you saw
on our show today from
our friends at Paul Works.